[Laughter]
hey you guys it's friday yeah
tom's staying at the ymca
oh i thought you were gonna do the whole
the whole thing i don't know how to do
it
i don't know how to make it i don't know
how to make letters it's been too long
since i've seen that [ __ ] i can't make
letters
i don't know what's going on for those
of you who follow me on facebook uh i've
been posting all day on facebook
not all day but i went down to the uh
biker bar around two
or one wasn't that one i think it might
have been earlier than that we're there
than that and cause you were down there
a long time yeah i drank all night and
it turns out when i went to go pay the
bills somebody else paid the bill
somebody else paid the bill for me so it
was free
free drinking
that's the best kind so yeah
yeah day drinking at the bike bar for
you always drinking so i was posting
videos of it he's living the dream yeah
it was pretty dead people coming and
going people just started to pick up as
i had to come back
i you know i decided to turn like around
four o'clock i had to start head back
because for the show is at five so
i'm [ __ ]
leaving and all the motorcycles are
showing up i'm like oh man i gotta
[ __ ] do the show
oh you have to actually do something
you've been there all day yeah i know
it was uh it was all right though
[ __ ] got some motorhead played in
there and people were putting clutch on
there and it was all right david june
says were you wearing your gay get up
when they paid your bill
that's why maybe something can get us on
there maybe maybe people some wanting
some stuff for painting
you guys are [ __ ] laughing
i posted it those [ __ ] bartenders
that have worked there [ __ ] that one
her name is amy
amy was swearing up and down that i was
a stripper
yeah she's a you're a stripper though
right
he's out there all naked with just a
little bow tie right because they're
strippers yeah they're strippers so they
so they're they think everyone else is
strippers too yeah they're they're extra
well he thinks few of the people that
look okay
and she says you know stripper says no
i'm not a stripper she's like come on
no i'm not a stripper it's just what's
your only fans
[Laughter]
so i swear to god because i don't have
it
and she's you don't have a homily fans
and i said do you have only fans and
she's like
no
and i said you got only fans don't you
she's like no
no no of course not why would i have
anything like that yes that's that but
anyway i'm not posting i post a video
that's [ __ ] funny you know
kanavatsan says must be that girlfriend
paying the tab yeah right
no actually he's in the video he's a
dude at the end of the bar he's he's
about my age and [ __ ] we were talking
about some paranormal [ __ ] he's [ __ ]
he was like he was interested in the
show
he had some poultry guy [ __ ] happened to
him when he was about 15. he's a great
man of time and
his parents saw it and he kept having
visions he was having visions
oh somebody had died in his family i was
kind of drunk i remember i don't
remember everyone but somebody had died
in his family and it scared him so bad
he kept having dreams that he was seeing
them in the oven
and uh like in the actual oven yeah in
the oven in the house creepy he would
have a dream that he saw them in the
oven in the house that's creepy and then
yeah
and they were they were dancing in the
flames in the oven and then um
uh
and then
i think he said that he had a vision
while he was awake
he saw them in the oven but it couldn't
have been true but they were it was um
pulling covers off and pulling on their
feet while they were
trying to go to sleep at night
he said his dad didn't believe it until
it [ __ ] pulled on his foot
and i was just that sounds like
poltergeist
and he goes yeah man it's funny it's
like you said man i was around 15 at
that time and uh you know
and um
he he's one of those guys that dreams
true and has out of body kind of
experiences but he's at the end of the
[ __ ] his name is uh brady brady
yeah so same age as me big shout out to
brady from yeah brady buddy
for your day drinking adventure yeah he
was having some he had some paranormal
[ __ ] happening when he was about my age
right my tummy is making all kind of
like growling noises
i just ate i had some i had some eggos
[Laughter]
yeah no need for me too you sent a super
chat before the show started he's
working on that mustang he's got a
spoiler coming in it's almost done
i forgot what year he said that mustang
was i think it was pre sn94
so
we're saying i'm looking like an old guy
jack yeah old man jacked old man
[Laughter]
yeah david's trying to get me a good
jest up in a gay outfit your
[ __ ] must be [ __ ] beating
down on a [ __ ] when i'm not
watching
i'm not looking and [ __ ] i turn
around and if
[Laughter]
tonight is
open line friday we talk about
everything on on a friday
any uh subject you guys want to talk
about jenny and i are probably prepared
for we've either done a show about it or
we've um
uh or we know about it or we'll just
make it up or we'll or
forward the research
right
or if you want clarification more on
stuff that we already did
um yeah we just kind of know how those
cases go
well you know this is this is the
sidetrack show but i kind of feel like
the one that we did on wednesday at the
zodiac show was also kind of a side
track show because i kind of felt like
we only talked about the topic for maybe
sophie is in the comments section
sophie benjamin
she goes 15 minutes stop in while
driving i don't know exactly what that's
talking about matter of fact we were
supposed to get a package today did you
get a package uh i did not get a package
okay i'm gonna go down there and check
you better go down and check well yeah
it's still only five
but i can go check here in a minute
i mean i didn't hear anything but i
can't really they don't i mean when
amazon prime comes they just leave [ __ ]
by the door they don't yeah
um no need for me too is asking me about
comics if i was ever in the comics i was
never into the comments themselves i
knew about them uh i knew
what was going on at the time you know
in the in the 80s and the 90s i remember
when spawn came in and when dark knight
came in i just um
before that time when i was younger i
was more into like heavy metal magazine
i loved it heavy metal eerie and creepy
i don't know if you guys remember eerie
and creepy they were some [ __ ] weird
cool
and mad magazine i was big into that oh
hold on let me go down and check that
yeah i liked that as well actually
gangbang etiquette
are you asking just the general chat i'm
not super experienced with that kind of
stuff i don't know what all the rules
are i don't know what like gangbang
party fowl would be
um
oh conor botswan says i was looking at
past episodes i was surprised that you
guys never did the lost city of atlanta
yeah i don't think we did it's weird i
thought we did but i think what it was
was that i'm gonna write it down
was that um
i used to write articles
uh about paranormal [ __ ] like for
another channel
and i think i did
either atlanta atlantis or lemuria or
whatever the hell and i think i wrote an
article about it so maybe that's why
because i thought i just wrote an
article about it but i thought we'd done
a show about it but i'll write it down
all right i wrote down crystal skulls
too because i think somebody said that
on wednesday
and uh you know
gangbang party fellow crossing swords
yeah i kind of feel like problems yes
your christmas present showed up oh okay
so good i was gonna say uh while you
were out day drinking today i actually
got all the christmas presents wrapped
because all your stuff is here i mean
that's it's not all the christmas cards
it was like five presents you know what
i mean because a couple and a couple of
them were for pookie and beijing and
that means that
most likely
most likely sophie's gonna get her
christmas present in two or three days
pokey
you hear myself you're on there you get
your
two or three days it should show up
don't open that [ __ ] till christmas
well i mean you're not going to be there
to stop her she can't if she wants to
it's wrapped you can tell what it is
when it shows up but don't you know what
i mean not exactly you'll kind of know
what it is
yeah it'll give you a hint it's wrapped
but it's just wrapped in brown paper and
again it tells you what company it is so
you'll know what it is
yeah talking about uh cracked magazine
in mad magazine yeah i remember when i
was a kid me and my brother used to get
mad magazine all the time
[ __ ] was kind of funny i loved mad
magazine
i liked the the remember the little
books
yeah from cygnet yeah yeah my cousin
wesley had all of them back in the 70s
pretty much all of them well which is
hundreds of them
and i used to love the spy versus spy
ones remember they had the yeah the
black and white spies you know but the
[ __ ] pointed look like birds kind of
i love those they kind of look like
plague doctors now like doctors yeah
but yeah uh but yeah i got all i got the
christmas presents wrapped while you
were gone
and
are they under the tree i didn't notice
no okay i put them uh well i wasn't sure
i was kind of like well one of them's
for pookie and beige and it has treats
in it and i kind of because remember
last year i had wrapped the presents
early and i put them under the tree and
pookie opened a couple of them yeah that
weren't even hers
right like or she didn't open them
completely but she completely like tore
paper off two sides of a few of the
presents because she's like oh are these
for me i'm just gonna because she likes
to eat paper yeah anything that's
crinkly they're talking about national
lampoon that was good i remember that
one but it was actually i think it was a
little
the subject matter was a little too over
my head at the time i was reading mad
i didn't really get national lampoon
that much
but back in the 70s a little kid i could
i could get about half of what mad
magazine was talking about because i was
like maybe eight seven eight nine yeah i
could understand about half of it some
of it i didn't quite get
so it was kind of an adult adult humor
yeah and a lot of it was i remember a
lot of it being like movie parodies and
stuff like that
yeah and they were parroting movies i
didn't see yeah so that probably doesn't
help yeah zack said why do we need a
sidetrack show we already had one this
week i know that's what i said zach go
ahead and check off
i'm gonna post i posted [ __ ] videos
from the uh from the uh from the biker
bar and zach's like man i'm really
impressed with that girl she's got
dimples on the back of her legs i was
like only a gay man would be [ __ ]
critiquing a woman that hard
i don't i don't think that's the case
[Laughter]
dimples on it that's that's player hate
though dj maniac says tom tell them
about the book i showed you yesterday
oh yeah dj maniac came across the uh
somebody through through the through the
shop that he works out came with [ __ ]
uh kind of a rare issue of den
which i was thinking oh man yeah
and i says that's worth some money and
he did the computation there's 150.
dan
dan has been out of print for a long
time if you've got a good copy of any of
the den magazines which is a fan sent me
two one or two
i think it was one one book from den
i priced it it was over a hundred
dollars so that's that's like a treasure
you know like okay yeah you don't sell
[ __ ] like that you just supposed to kind
of keep it you know
i don't believe in selling that kind of
stuff
but it's just
den is kind of uh if you understand the
heavy the the era of heavy metal
den is featured in the movie heavy metal
one of the segments
and he's just kind of this bald muscle
dude well actually it's happening in a
parallel universe he's just skinny
nobody in this world but in the other
world he's this bald muscle dude running
across all these big thick fine
women and [ __ ] he's laying them and
he's kind of like conan and he's trying
to save the world and he's not all that
bright you know but he does get the [ __ ]
done you know [ __ ] trying to stop bad
bad guys from doing bad things to
[ __ ] hot women and saving the world
you know which is just some heroic [ __ ]
and um yeah it's kind of the essence of
of heavy metal especially the 70s late
70s early 80s heavy metal it had that
vibe too it was very
male fantasy
heavy metal was was by guys for guys it
was
which i think that was the success of it
women didn't buy comic books back then i
don't know not back then yeah they don't
they didn't and i don't think they
really buy them now
um i've never done it yeah i mean
honestly i think it's a lot different
than it used to be well because we've
talked about this too with like horror
movies and stuff and i'm not saying
there weren't chicks that liked horror
movies back then but it's a lot more
common nowadays and nobody thinks it's
all that strange yeah um and honestly
when they've done
uh you know polls or whatever like of
demographics of people that go see
horror movies it's about 50 50.
depending on what the movie is contrary
to what some people might tell you
they've got women out there that just
love that [ __ ] purely male oriented
high testosterone [ __ ] some women just
love it you know not all women but there
there's a certain
like like sophie's big into that kind of
[ __ ] she's into that [ __ ]
she i called her
the other day i [ __ ] posted the
[ __ ] video jimi hendrix a machine gun
and i [ __ ] tagged all my army buddies
in it you know because jimi hendrix was
in the same unit i was in
327 to 101st
he didn't make it to vietnam he got hurt
in a jump
but uh
but there's still a statue to jimi
hendrix uh at four campbell outside the
101 club at least it was when i was
there
um so he is honored by the 101st
um
even during the um kind of vietnam
protest era
hendrix never spoke ill of the troops he
didn't approve of of vietnam
but he never said anything to demoralize
the troops and they would tried to make
him say bad things about trump he
wouldn't do that um
but anyway uh i posted that
song and i happened to just [ __ ] i
posted i [ __ ] tagged all my friends
army buddies in it
and i i threw sophie in there too and
she was like what are you tagging me and
this for with all your badass army
friends and i says because you're like
an army groupie and she goes yeah you're
not wrong she likes that she likes that
kind of [ __ ] so
so there are some women that are really
into the into kind of
the uh
real [ __ ] macho me testosterone type
stuff
like by man four man type [ __ ] they got
women that are into that which i
understand it because there's some stuff
that's like super feminine that i think
is fascinating too it just depends on
the tone of it
you know and and what the message is
oh like i said it all it all just
depends
well i mean
you can make generalizations about
people but generally i mean there's
anything that there is there's people
that like that and there's probably a
certain percentage of people that you
wouldn't expect to like that that do
like that
so you know that's probably true for
everything
yeah uh oracle who's still uh you know
we're still
pulling for you out there not sure if uh
about the cancer diagnosis
uh so
just sending good thoughts your way
uh says jenny on the true crime front
have y'all ever done an ep on bass
reeves the us marshall an inspiration
for the lone ranger we have not but i
did write it down uh because like i said
i'm always looking for new topics i'm
like running out of stuff no need for me
to say yeah den is awesome from heavy
metal
um
and then
uh dj says he says yeah they had that
magazine been sitting in that shop for
about six months and i just noticed it
last night while back while i was
cleaning and then later on he says the
boss took it home so it's probably gone
forever yeah
and it appraised for 150 bucks
i'm telling you man a den book is worth
a lot now i saw i saw the online prizes
and different issues different editions
are worth different amounts
some of the stuff with what
wasn't printed in in large numbers so a
lot of that [ __ ] if it's 150 200 that's
one of the rarer ones i didn't off ha i
didn't immediately recognize the cover
of that dead book i forgot what the name
of it was
it was some kind of weird
title the way it was spelled
yeah zach is saying i'm surprised there
haven't been uh many vietnam war based
horror movies and there's a lot of
vietnam based regular movies but not a
lot yeah now that you think about it
there are a couple yeah somebody brought
up jacob's ladder yeah um tales from the
dark side did an episode with zombies in
vietnam
yeah there's been like little stuff like
that but yeah i really don't yeah
um and somebody brought up house from
1986 which had a little bit i mean it
was a guy that was in vietnam
but you don't see a lot that like take
place in vietnam i guess house had like
um flashbacks and stuff soph chimes and
he goes yeah it's fascinating thing kind
of like the way tom feels about women's
shoes and fashions laughing my ass off
yes that's true that's true [ __ ] i
can get into women's clothes all [ __ ]
day
i can't and makeup schemes and [ __ ] i
love that [ __ ]
but i wouldn't i'm not wearing that
though it's just that it's just super
feminine i understand i just kind of
it's a fetish thing i guess you could
say you know yeah i suppose it's a
fetish thing like well that looks good
you know
that's that's i'm into that
gram there's hammer says why are some
women attracted attracted to mgtow types
do they hate themselves or do they just
want to challenge well it could be it
could be either one of those things
could be both things be rejected
women don't like to be rejected well
nobody does nobody does
you asked me the other day you said how
does a mgtow type guy attract